we want these nubs to be toyed excuse me
could we wrap the flowers in new york
times crossword puzzles from key dates
in our lives oh
is that something you'd like
here's the deposit i designed you a
signature cocktail i call it
the
peraltiago
and the judges give it a score of
jeremy did you make that cake that i
called you about yes i wasn't entirely
sure if you were joking or not
but a nakatomi plaza cake
the groom is out of licorice house
welcome to the wedding pal
oh amy these nups may be getting too
tight
listen up everybody we are getting
married in a public rec center
super cheap on a basketball court weeks
week with one working bathroom ladies
gotta wait
and it's in deep staten island
destination wedding y'all
but the point is these nuptials are
still gonna be
mad toy i would marry you in a dumpster
oh i would marry you in a dumpster
friends colleagues gawking new yorkers
we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of jake peralta and amy
santiago
i've known you both for the last five
years and it has been a true pleasure to
watch your distracting childish rivalry
evolve into a distracting childish
courtship and now
into what i'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage
i'm proud of you and i love you both
permission to say it back permission
grounded love you sir love you captain
now i believe you prepared your own vows
yes
i was going to do an adams family-themed
wrap but my beatboxer isn't here that's
the only reason it's not happening
so ames
today has been a crazy day but
i shouldn't be surprised because we've
had a lot of crazy days
there was our first date our first kiss
the first time you told me you loved me
and the day
you told me you would marry me also
yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
because every single day that i get to
be with someone as amazing as you
is crazy to me i love you
and i'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends
the end okay
well i've been planning this wedding for
the last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong
i would have had a panic attack that
sent me into the er
but i'm here and i've never been happier
life is unpredictable not everything's
in our control but as long as you're
with the right people you can handle
anything and you jake peralta
are the right person for me but i do
have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too i can't wait to spend the
rest of my life with you
i've been thinking and i do want to have
kids
with you you're not scared anymore oh no
i am so scared
maybe even more so than before but i was
scared in there with pam too
and you know i didn't panic or mess
anything up there if anything i was
sharper and it was a freaking debate
genius
debate genius oh that's very hot oh
that's an added bonus okay keep that
energy up but the point that i was
actually trying to make is
maybe it's a good thing that i'm scared
of fatherhood you know maybe it'll turn
me into a
friggin dad genius i thought i might be
pregnant
really yeah i'm not i got my period and
i took a pregnancy test but it didn't
work because i drank 11 gallons of water
i told you water is bad for you that's
not the takeaway you're absolutely
right how are you how do you feel are
you okay i mean i was really stressed
this wasn't our plan and we agreed we'd
wait a year and there's so much to do
first and it would have been crazy right
yeah
it would have been okay but
also might have been kind of cool
honestly i was secretly bummed when the
test came back negative
should we just start trying seriously
yeah seriously okay
[Music]
why is it so easy for everyone else to
get pregnant
wait look at these stupid guinea pigs
they made 600 babies and we can't make
one
why can't we make 600 babies you can't
compare yourself to guinea pigs babe
you taught me that i'm exhausted and the
universe keeps telling us that it
doesn't want us to have a baby the
message couldn't be clearer so
i'm done like done for this month
done just done
i've been thinking about what you said
this morning and it has been a really
hard
couple of months i'm sorry i'm bad at
making babies
hey hey don't say that it's not your
fault and look for all we know i could
have don't
say you have bum nards
i wasn't gonna but i think maybe it's
just a thing we can't control that is my
least favorite kind of thing
i know i really wanted to start a family
amy we are a family
you and me so you know we can keep
trying or
look into ivf or adoption or if we want
we can forget about the whole thing but
if we're together i'm happy
no matter what i don't know what i want
to do
fine it's okay too we don't have to have
a plan
we make the rules you know maybe it
would help to just not think about the
whole thing for a while
and see where we're at yeah okay
i love you i love you
should we go yes okay
nope
i don't know if you noticed but ever
since i started those hormone treatments
i didn't notice anything
you said that way too quick i mean you
did cry at that one car commercial and
it wasn't even an emotional one it was
about towing capacity yeah
well i called the doctor to see if that
was a common side effect and
apparently it isn't oh no
is everything okay yeah she did have one
guess as to what might be causing it
and um she was right
ames are we having a baby
we're having a baby
it happened just keep pushing you're
almost there no but jake's not here yet
sam i'm here oh jake i can't believe i
made it
i'm going to see the birth of my oh
we're on page 53. babe we're on page 53.
dino i rode a horse
well we did it ames we made the world's
hottest baby
so cute jake no this kid is liquid fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven of the
number one draft pick for the knicks
hmm and then he's gonna pass up that
opportunity to pursue his true passion
library sciences well the important
thing is we'll support him no matter
what
even if he's a huge huge nerd oh
especially then
are we gonna be okay at this i mean this
entire day felt like a warning from the
universe
i almost missed the birth we had our
baby at the precinct a firefighter
touched our child
we washed him off yeah but i'll always
know babe we talked about this
everyone balances working kids yeah but
everyone's not a cop
true but when our son wants to hear
about the day he was born
we get to tell him that his dad helped a
bunch of people
and foiled a bank robbery
i guess that is kind of cool and his mom
managed a city-wide emergency while
actually giving birth
i'm proud for her son to have you as a
dad
me too for you to be the mom
i was just agreeing with the nice thing
you said about me i love you
love you too oh my god he's beautiful
oh jake he's got your face charles
meet mac short for mclean i said surely
i love it
no as in john from die hard i mean
they're both incredibly cool it's only
one oscar winner
thanks for getting jake there in time oh
don't thank me
the real hero is lieutenant peanut
butter
no it was all you charles or should i
say
uncle chi-chi don't ruin this moment for
yourself uncle charles it is
how's he doing he's perfect i see you
changed oh yeah that other outfit had a
lot of after birth on it also
during birth and pre-birth the point is
i burned it thanks for staying by my
side
i know it wasn't easy for you it's worth
it i'm auntie roro
she gets to be ro-ro incredible seven
years away for this
captain lieutenant the dance was great
and it really helped thank you dance
what dance she doesn't know what she's
talking about
mommy brain much captain holt and i did
a hip-hop dance routine
oh i see well you know what
i don't even care that i missed it
because right now i am holding
my son and there's nothing more
important in the world than that i have
a video if you want to see it amy hold
this baby rosie give me that phone
give me that phone everyone wash your
hands
you